uno de los principales acuerdos fue en
que se va a seguir trabajando para una
reapertura total de la frontera entre
Colombia y Venezuela llamada la atención
lo que decía el presidente Gustavo Petro
que esta vía quedado en manos de mafias
que había que combatir y otro de los
puntos importantes Era sobre cuál sería
la postura de Nicolás maduro sobre esa
petición que le ha hecho Petro en dos
oportunidades de Volver al sistema
interamericano de Derechos Humanos lo
escuchaban ustedes Nicolás Maduro decía
que ha sido receptivo en cuanto a esto y
que se iba a evaluar en las próximas
semanas pero no rechazó esta decisión
también se habló de la reincorporación
de Venezuela a la comunidad andina de
Naciones y se le iba a solicitar a los
otros países miembros la incorporación
de Venezuela hablaron además de tener
una postura común para la copa que se va
a realizar en Egipto en las próximas
semanas sobre la amazonía llamó la
atención en este encuentro que en
principio vimos a un Gustavo Petro algo
incómodo cuando llegó al palacio de
Miraflores no fue muy receptivo el
saludo y el estrechón de manos con el
presidente Nicolás Maduro sin embargo
dos horas después de una reunión a
puertas cerradas se le vio llamas cómodo
y risas entre ambos mandatarios una
declaración conjunta en el salón
ayacucho del Palacio de Miraflores pero
no se permitió preguntas por parte de
los medios de comunicación que asistimos